well it's national random acts of
kindness day so what better way
to to talk about it about raising money
for non-profits across the valley
miracle mile shops
believe it or not they have an indoor
rainstorm and that rainstorm
collects change for the just one project
eight news now reporter bianca holman is
here to tell us
all about it she's live at planet
hollywood with the details good morning
bianca
hey good morning sherry when the rain
storm is happening throughout the day
which it does on the hour
people take change or dollar bills and
they toss it in there for good luck
right well now that good luck is going
to
a wonderful organization that helps so
many here in the valley and to tell us
more about
this effort i'm joined here by wendy and
brooke who's representing the
organization but wendy tell us more
about
uh what miracle mild shops is doing here
at the rainstorm what we're doing
through the december 31st is that we're
really excited to be working with the
just one project so whenever you come to
miracle mile shops whether you're
shopping or eating
you can come by the rainstorm you can
throw some change in and all the money
goes to the just one project
and all their great causes that they're
in the wonderful work that they're doing
here in the community
and if you don't have change on you we
do have a qr code right here on our sign
you can just take a picture of that with
your phone and it'll automatically go
right to the just one project website
and you can donate directly perfect so
again if you don't have change in your
pocket or in your seat it's okay you can
still give
by giving electronically to tell us more
about the the project i'm joined here by
brooke tell us more about your
organization
so the just fun project connects the
community through giving back and
volunteerism
we have a really great program called
food for all that we're always looking
for volunteers to come and help
hand out food at our farmers market type
setting and also too we have an amazing
homebound senior delivery grocery
program and so we're always looking for
volunteers for that it's really just an
amazing way to connect with the
community and really just
give a lending hand to somebody in need
perfect helping our neighbors whether
it's someone who lives right next door
to you someone who lives across the
valley
and wendy tell us this is not just
happening today or this month right this
is happening
all year long we can give yeah actually
this is part of our caring giving
changing program that we started in 2010
and this year um all the way through
december 31st all the money will go to
the just one project
incredible and tell us you know again
this is the money that's collected here
i know it means a lot to you guys brooke
this is going to change someone's life
absolutely it really takes something so
small to make a difference whether you
come here and you throw a couple bucks
in the fountain or your extra change or
you deliver
groceries to somebody who has zero food
in the pantry i mean it really could be
a life-changing gesture so
perfect okay wonderful and of course
we're gonna tweet out this information
it's going to be on our website
and if you come if you're even staying
here on the strip and you're just
visiting know that when you come here to
miracle mile shops
you're going to leave an important
impact here on our community
by helping those in need we're going to
send it back to you guys in the studio
all right thanks bianca anybody who
keeps a money jar at home
knows how quickly it can add up so think
about
putting that money towards good use like
that thanks so much
and we'll just toss our coins in the
fountain and bring somebody else good
luck for a change